look it's all great to be on social  media you know it's a part of the fabric  of our society of our lives and kids  should be able to go out and create  accounts and be able to express  themselves it's all good but it's got to  be monitored and the thing that drives  me crazy guys  is you see these parents who are  exploiting their children not in this  case i'm not arguing that in the case of  naples but in other cases and i've done  stories on this where parents are  pimping out their kids in these quote  unquote family  channels  and and youtube sometimes doesn't  crack down on this stuff  so they'll  limit monetization on a on a show that i  do exposing this stuff  but the young girl who's being exploited  that show is fine they monetize the the  heck out of it it's it's insane